but I think Jorah probably more than
most has teetered on the edge of his own
demise
[Music]
so what was your reaction when you read
your script for your final episode what
was your initial reaction um just that
the guys that nailed it you know I think
throughout really all the episodes
yeah just wonderful writing kind of you
know it's such a hard thing to pull off
I think you know the expectations are so
high and yeah I think they just managed
all the storylines incredibly well and
you know it's full of the Thrones mix of
the unexpected and the dramatic and you
know massive set pieces and yeah
extraordinary happenings and things
beyond our care it's kind of more the
same bigger better
[Music]
I was really happy yeah I was really
happy please was there ever a point with
in Game of Thrones that you thought that
you're gonna get axed earlier just about
the entire yeah all seasons throughout
the entire thing yeah yes I did get a
phone call at 1 points from the
producers and they said we want to have
a dinner with you and I was like and
that at that point I think that was sort
of the the talk was that you when you
went to dinner with them they were gonna
nicely let you go and it was just it
turned out just to be a lovely dinner
but I was I can swear in America know
it's sort of one of the cost favorite
questions to Dan and David Samadi into
next and they always say yeah use the
agency so yeah they always toyed with us
made us suffer well our to Heidi's
how grueling was it for you guys to film
all the battles that you've had this
year would you remember the dream jihad
it was really cold and it went bomb for
like 50 nights and it was really cold we
were all in the middle of Northern
Ireland freezing in a place called -
yeah it was it was you know it was more
it was in the dead of Northern Irish
winter I mean I know like here in New
York you you have them pretty harsh too
but it was also because of the time
thing because they were night shoots you
know it's hot so it's like being
constantly jet-lagged
remember that dream the recurring dream
you had like this mess 30 nights in a
row
this must be this must be this must be
something in you or a fantasy yeah it's
really cold I also imagine that it's
actually snowing so like you're cold all
of your like extremities are cold but
then on top of that like the snow stops
and then suddenly someone shouts in the
background like get the fake snow in and
then someone just pops you before this
chemical snow just me yeah bit of rest
by you like awesome I think that's like
a lot of it was like that because that
you get you just get like a little wind
and you're like oh woman now and then
it's like everything stuff it's up again
yeah I just need to go on holiday yeah
thanks warm and sunny sec
you